hey you thank you for tuning into
GameSpot after dark if you want to skip
ahead we've got timestamps below and for
more gaming news you're already in the
right place hello welcome to episode 28
of GameSpot after dark
your weekly video game podcast where we
drink beer and sometimes talk about
video games this week joining me is Lucy
James Oh Callie plaguey I and John McGee
so he chugged his beer so if you're
listening to audio I'm very sorry No
hello that's why we you know drinking
and kind of talk about I'm fine well
anyway how's everyone doing well John
Luke is reaching for another beer Koh
start I know yes last night I was trying
to exfoliate my face using a single
blade facial razor it's all the rage and
seen him on tik-tok big skincare trend
right now and I had a lot of dry skin
cuz the heat in my house has been on and
I ended up slicing my thumb open and I
almost passed out that was pretty fun
it's doing better today but at first I
was really freaked out I was like that's
a lot of blood I don't know how deep I
cut it and then I had to sit down in the
bathroom like yeah that's your week in
the in a nutshell it's it's good it's
not in a place where it's gonna
interfere with my gaming ability oh
that's good it's interfering with my
texting ability that's what's important
though yeah yeah really like I could
play pokemon just fine it's just I can't
really text quickly so that always be a
big concern wherever I injure finger or
something like that like I remember
doing swim team one time I collided with
someone else's hand and like I think
I've messed up my thumb or something I
think I fractured
something like that and my biggest
concern was that I wasn't gonna be able
to play video games I broken my arm a
toe and each ankle four times oh my god
touchwood I mean that's not wood I think
that's some kind of fake this might be
would touch would never broken hey
listen
[Music]
[Laughter]
email that went out today we got an Appy
arm email that first of all I did not
receive and you will understand why in a
second you were so upset but you didn't
get it yeah because the subject line of
the email was show us your meet comma
and then the the recipients name so it
was like show us your meet Alessandra
show us your meet Michael and I was like
interesting that they didn't send me
they show me show us your meet I used to
be on pornhub email press list
specifically for games like they would
send me they would send info first of
all that came from a gmail account port
of games at gmail.com like that PR
person at gmail.com and they would just
send these infographics about usually
timed so I remember the overwatch one Oh
talking about trends in searches for
particular characters but then they
would send this infographic and there
would be a link and it would go click
here to go to the safe for work
infographic click it and it would still
be on the pornhub domain it's like look
at porn huh don't worry I'll be like I'm
at work I'm like but I do want to know
but then I click it and you know it's
fine that that page was safe but it did
still have the logo and it says the URL
right cbs's so someone in CVS is like I
wonder I wonder what websites the games
teams are going to and then the defense
of pornhub we do have like goriest kills
montage videos so like you know I mean
it's true and also a lot of people like
diva I've been advocating that we should
just start uploading all of our
start videos on on pornhub Oh wasn't
that a thing when fall out for the
opening a fall I thought a king France
three-two leaked onto pornhub yeah also
we should I mean wow
not to tangent very very quickly this
week but there is a fantastic podcast by
Jon Ronson called the butterfly effect
which is all about the founding of
pornhub and just the weird sort of
butterfly effects that came from just
this guy in the Netherlands wanting to
put free porn on the internet and it is
fascinating it's free it used to be
inaudible pronounced free there's also a
documentary on Netflix about Japanese oh
the director the naked dude yes yea
Japanese porn industry
yeah really important arresting industry
is different because there's all sorts
of like a censoring but he he was like
done for poor choice of words he was
like in Hawaii for something there was a
bunch of money involved and his whole
story is very very feel like not the
norm when it comes to working in the
adult entertainment industry remember
when um I never went but CES and the AVN
yes yes yeah that's my first thing yes
this year but unfortunately video games
oh yeah before actually we do that we're
gonna we have the Dayton Ohio 2.1 hours
from Dayton Ohio 2.1 patchnotes sent in
by kevin we've done this already we see
myself in Cali but John Luke you've not
done it yet no so I figure we'll test
out version 2.1 on you i think you
should start with the questions but then
after we're done with the questions read
Kevin's patch notes at the top because
they highlight what's different and I
think they're very clever okay okay
number one
and mmo's DPS healer or tank DPS in
Pokemon grass fire or water starter
typically fire sonic or Mario Mario life
is strange Walking Dead gone home or
what remains of Edith Finch life is
strange games that made you the angriest
our game that made you that's made you
the angriest um I have no idea that one
wasn't an arse down I was gonna say
mines Modern Warfare mile-high club I
got really mad at that
no I did get really mad at that too I'll
say that I'm sure there's something else
that got me more angry but that
definitely got me upset
actually not no halo 2 legendary Oh
yellow two legendary hero two legendary
us because that's when they added if one
person dies yeah yeah but I remember two
is like the first three missions were
the hardest and once he got through
those it wasn't too bad yeah I got it
got easier and then Anka other brutes
were kind of [ __ ]
yeah a Mortal Kombat or Street Fighter
probably mortal kombat halo overwatch
quake siege or Call of Duty halo most
desired smash Ultimate Edition oh I'll
cure you linear or open-world Ben's
probably very happy linear uh in FPS
games shotgun assault rifle or sniper
rifle shotgun co-op single-player or
multiplayer co-op Xbox Playstation
Nintendo PC or Ouya PC favorite
controller ever
probably a 360 controller I don't know
if I like I probably prefer the 1x now
because it's kind of where to go back to
but like at the time I was like this
controller is so perfect so oh that one
pop-tarts our toaster strudel toaster
strudel is it cheating if a friend tells
you how to beat a part you're stuck on
nope is it cheating if you save scum now
Danny O'Dwyer Dan Reichert Danny O'Dwyer
I remember you all were like I plead the
fifth I think we all went we all ended
up with Danny's game on a couch or at a
desk
hmm depends on the game but I guess
death dusk favorite gaming snack Oh
pretzels no there's nothing to yeah
Miyazaki Sakurai Miyamoto Kodaka or
Kojima
Kodaka a creator of danganronpa out of
those Miyazaki but I would if I had to
pick a different Japanese developer I'd
say Hideki Kamiya Oh better add that
looks like we're gonna need 2.2
so his updates as his patch notes are
question four and five combined answer
opinion Jesus question four and five
combined answer options and added new
question five to reduce grinding
[Laughter]
question 7 added quake as an option due
to balancing issues as a quick fan I do
respect that the hadith at question 8
eliminated mouse or keyboard and
replaced it replaced it a new quest
replaced it with a new question after a
rare podcast breaking tangent bug
probably replaced on Rails with linear
as the developer forgot the later the
latter existed question 20 added Kodaka
by popular request very good that's
really good it's good but we're gonna
need a 2.2 because we got to add yeah
um season what sorry he's the one who
block several on Twitter right yeah sure
which is one of the Kickstarter goals
yeah wonderful 101 yeah if you donate
enough money he'll block you on Twitter
dude if you just do that without you
just tweet him he will block you that's
true but maybe won't now I love the idea
of paying money to have him [ __ ] I hope
you like says something too before he
does give you a bug like a little bit I
have no time answering question from
this insect yeah yeah by the way if
anybody wants me to block them go ahead
and like the movie yeah that's a good
way to make money money on the side
mm-hmm I was thinking about feed pigs
really that's what we were talking about
I was like is it weird to be like
researching only fans I don't I've never
been on it how do you I've never been on
it I feel like it just became a thing -
thank you - see what the whole deal was
but see the thing is it's basically like
a patreon but yes it is my vids is the
same thing just don't ask video games
now we should talk about video games
this is the Valentine's Day episode
that's happy about get your partner only
fan subscription if my girlfriend's
listening to this she knows what I want
all right
we've we've gone some places this
episode but why don't we get out of here
let's get out here as quick as we can
because Lucy's gonna talk about Sonic
the Hedgehog okay so it's not just me
who saw this oh are you saying we need
to escape from the city 70 did play
escape from the city did no no not not
in the movie unfortunately but they did
play it in the theater
like before I know it doesn't cut it
doesn't count but it was got my turn
yeah I think we should start a petition
and they should take that movie back to
lay it for another couple months and
then what about what's the other one
that we always do and we're platonic
heroes yeah sonic heroes what goes up
must come down
that's how I remember I thought I felt
like they played that in the lobby too
today they played that I think they
played so anyway the Sonic the Hedgehog
movie you guys saw it yeah Carolee it
was good so fizzle I was concerned I
mean we were all had concerns about that
film right and then we got the invite
for the screening and chastity who's
handling it was like they're just
letting as many of us go as we want so a
whole load of us went down he was saying
she only expected like three people our
responders like 17 of us yeah because it
was at 10 a.m. on a Saturday morning
yeah so that's typically what they do
for screenings of kids films is because
obviously the kids are awake at like 6
a.m. our EP anyway if we went down and I
have to report to you it's my solemn
duty to report to you that Sonic the
Hedgehog is a good movie not a good
video game movie it's a good movie I
laughed more it's Sonic the Hedgehog I
enjoyed something Hedgehog more than I
know they're not really comparable but
knives out
uncut gems which I sold both of those
recently are a bit like well Uncle Jim's
is stressful but I didn't get any kind
of satisfied Hedgehog has a hundred
percent less vomit than knives outright
yes yes yeah I was thinking there was no
bomb inside it's genuinely funny for the
most part for the most there's some
whiffs a floss sonic floss is I regret
to inform you all the sonic flossers
twice there's a bit there's a bit where
so Jim Carrey's Robotnik Becker's full
Jim Carrey and there is a scene where he
just dances and it's like it's like
Oscars I feel I feel like you like wanna
like you know like a like a tick-tock
dance yeah like one of those no no I
don't think he'd be there in stabs Jim
Carrey's skin kinda holds probably he
can move he's trying to be Mimi about it
just felt like Jim Carrey just went off
I feel like the filmmakers had nothing
to do that and Jim Carrey was like just
watch me go why he was green-screen some
stuff that man had you an incredible
amount of control over his facial
muscles oh yeah you seen that clip of
him doing the green trees I think that's
a 100% what I was thinking of yeah yeah
he's absolutely the best part of that
film hands down yeah so we went and I
was talking to Gary Whitta about it
because he was there with his kid and
his wife and he made a very good point
that the son of the Hedgehog movie
basically borrows a lot the same beats
as et there were bits in that film
nobody's a very funny
Sonic is very likable he's not is
irritating he he and james marsden
character play off each other really
really well james marsden incredible in
that role like if you say if you watch a
lot of movies where you know big-name
actors have to face off against a small
animated thing I think James Madison
does an amazing job he's very funny I
mean has has the range he does he was in
27 dresses
oh yeah and Westworld so like oh and
that Amy Adams movie about she thinks
she's a fantasy hair Enchantix also put
some respect on Scott
as from x-men his breakout long yeah oh
wow yeah yeah where he was a limp no wet
blanket
anyway Sonic is really good I really
enjoyed it I don't think it's really
good this is me I don't play Sonic games
I never liked Sonic I I mean I regret to
inform you I've played every Sonic game
but I wouldn't call myself a Sonic fan
yeah that was yeah it was a there was
some worrying about his like if just
Sonic's ass there was a there's a bit
where Sonic is just lying on the ground
and the camera just pans into his ass
and I'm like I don't like where this is
going I think it just had well first off
I thought the opening the opening like
five minutes was like a little rough
because it's very he's just narrating it
I don't know i yeah they try and do a
Deadpool thing and it was a little like
oh I'm not the biggest fan of that like
once I got past that I was better in
anything so okay if you were to put this
movie into your ranking of Sonic video
games though like how close is it to the
top I mean like most of those are
trashed so like I know the parts not
that I mean the bars pretty low but like
what what's the top of the bar like
what's the best video game movie Oh best
video game movie I mean just like for
reference here like I want to know where
sonic would fall compared really good
Pikachu's really good I like doom with
the rock I know that wasn't very good
like the second one the first Resident
Evil movie though that was like good for
a video game movie yeah it's like that
is like textbook good for a video game
movie do like anime adaptations of anime
games count no it's got to be
live-action like I would say Sonic is it
it is like a above like like yours if
you're
think of like your very typical standard
like kids movie like The Smurfs or like
a trolls that kind of thing I would it's
definitely but it's not a Pixar but like
we're no no it's not a Pixar but above
cars 3 though like Pixar like a car
sorry I couldn't what kind of a Shrek
what's the Shrek barometer
like where is it like never as good as
Shrek 2 Shrek 2 Shrek - you can't go of
quality hey Shrek quality has just never
gotten any better than that
but kids yeah I think sonic is is a it's
a great kids it's a great kids baby it's
like definitely better than than the
average kids maybe Krampus there are
some incredible puns in it too so I
really felt about all of gardening jokes
yeah Jason's character is like moving to
San Francisco to become a cop and his
wife's like I've been looking at
apartments on Zillow and I was like this
is too real but then the apartment that
they showed for the price that they
showed I was that going [ __ ] what we're
in San Francisco are you finding that
San Francisco plays a major role in this
movie which is also why it's
disappointing the escape from the city
isn't play because that level is based
on San Francisco they did show the CBS
right now what point freeze frames and
you're like that's the CBS sonic just
ran past our building heading to the
Metreon yep yeah okay but I realized
also is weird you can tell where they've
changed the his face yeah so some scenes
just like you can just see it it's not
as good it's still great and it's super
a awful lot and unfortunately all those
people like worked all that time all
that overtime to fix it and then all the
media lost their jobs the VFX industry
is a nightmare yeah I mean all the stuff
oh Gordon and rebel Wilson at the Oscars
- they went on stage in cat costumes to
take the piss out of the cats movie but
obviously all the VFX artists who broke
their backs to work on it were like well
this has nothing to do with us this has
everything to do with the way the film
was shot and the creative vision in
action we were literally just told to
make it we probably would because didn't
they film it without like motion
tracking dots everything is done pretty
much manually oh that's a nightmare yeah
anyway
Sonic I enjoyed well I'm sad I thought
speaking of Zillow I thought I had an
apartment viewing that morning
oh they got moved so I could have gone I
am wearing the beanie oh you got a
beanie Sonic beanie I really was a guy
that who was wearing a big Mega Man
jacket nice oh yeah he had like a huge
mega man Jack yeah like a sonic hat but
I like I like that just like small yes
what Sam said yes I'm here from the 90s
tomorrow was wearing all blood-borne
stuff I'm sure blood-borne jackass I
don't remember
I think he's where's Taco Bell [ __ ] he
was yes I just my mom was the one who
taught me how to play Sonic c-usa and my
mom's blows tickets to go see Sony no no
she's I mean my my parents had a Genesis
so I didn't have like a Super Nintendo
and we played a lot of Sonic and my mom
figured out the Chaos Emerald [ __ ] on
her own and Wow mom
her stomach I played was on the gamegear
because my friend had a game gear and I
played and I thought it was cool cuz I
played sonic on it the battery only
lasted like an hour and a half though
and then I have to put eight more
double-a batteries I don't think it was
eight but it was bad actually it may
have been eight before I it was it was
yes orbiting for hate I should call
Peter Brown he would yeah Peter wouldn't
know yeah anyway that's what I've been
doing
just watching it over and over and over
Wow no the other thing we didn't is I've
started watching Mad Men I think I said
that last week didn't I I've never seen
it I haven't seen it either I've been
told it's very good it's one episode and
the like this the like microaggressions
towards women made me uncomfortable just
because it was like oh it's in the
station where the women are sort of like
fighting back but they were doing just
microaggressions against the men but
it's it's very weird that I go between
in the course of one episode I will go
between absolutely loving Don Draper and
then just thinking he is absolutely he
sucks
but he has so much range in like depth
that I really love it to be clear it's
not that I think the show is bad because
of that it just pisses I mean yeah I
haven't gone through workplace [ __ ] like
that it's just you know not something I
needed to I was like yeah I think I came
out around the it was like airing at the
same time as Breaking Bad which which
which I was watching and I was like I
don't know if I need multiple shows
about a terrible protagonist mm-hmm
that's very good though it is Gavin if
he's at favorite show of all time
so I update him every night and he wakes
up really early so just at the point
where I'm going to bed he'll message me
about the episode that I've just seen
it's very good that's cute I think Mike
likes that show a lot - it's one of his
favorites as well I should probably
message Mike about it - mmhmm like oh my
god the ending of season 1 well I mean
he'll message you after he listens to
this episode so jean-luc would have a
bunch of old stuff actually I finished
playing Halo 2 co-op speak a little
again um with my girlfriend because
we've been she's never played halo and
we were like looking for a new cough
game and we're like let's play through
all the halos so we're playing Halo
we played halo 2 and had a really fun
time I really know if I have anything
else to say about it other than I don't
know yellow - still slaps that
soundtrack the lip liners and Master
Chief's one-liners there also
they're all cheesy but they're also good
I love them so much
yes I must have been annoying the [ __ ]
out of her because so we played halo 1
waiting for all the line yes we played a
loved one which is what if you miss I
won't know I tell the Covenant I'm
giving back their bomb my favorite thing
is the things the grunts say about you
and my brother and I will go around my
parents house being like the demon is
here cuz cuz halo 1 was it's so
interesting going from halo on a halo 2
and being like wow they like really like
and they really like stepped it up a lot
like halo 2 is like so much more of a
story to it where it's like trying to
like get into like the religious
politics of the Covenant which is like
interesting but kind of weird yeah it
like doesn't quite work but it works
enough it works enough and it was like
we love sci-fi with religious overtones
don't we lose house target but it just
sent me back to like middle school drama
playing it and I was like I'm so sorry
you're gonna have middle school Jean
okay and I'm just like talking about
like all these Easter eggs and like
things you can do and I'm like quoting
all the lines in the cutscenes and you
get all the schools just sitting there
being like I love the re I still love
the the when you first plays the arbiter
mm-hmm and you just come out of the in
the cloak and then like throw out the
sword and it's just like I get to use
the sword and it was like so cool but
then energy sword Sunday yeah you know
we did have an energy source and a thank
you uh yeah so we played that that's
really good I'm excited to play three
because it's my favorite and 3
multiplayer yeah 3 multiplayer was too
when I played the mouse um hello I love
to use multiplayer as well the other
game we've been playing is the Phoenix
Wright HD collection
I've never played Phoenix Wright before
but I'm kind of shocked I haven't just
because like it is so my jam because
it's just a like my a bike PC style
point click adventure game but you're
like solving murders and like
investigating and like talking to
witnesses and
it's so anime in its drama we're like
the current case we're on is like like a
person's been murdered but another
person was stabbed in a different
building 30 minutes at the exact same
time and it was the same person and
you're like trying to - yeah so you're
trying to figure like it's it's just so
it's it's real yeah like I feel like
we're gonna go to danganronpa after I
feel like because it's like okay we've
played yaku's that we've played persona
we've played like Phoenix right that was
the last piece of the puzzle to then
combine it all together to play
danganronpa I would be so proud and
honored
he played dangan ronpa we will get to it
we will definitely get to it but I'm
having a really good time with Phoenix
right it's it's it holds up very well
speaking of which I'm so excited for
murder by numbers Oh cross game oh god I
love so much wait it's a murder mystery
pick cross game yes yeah it is so is it
like Phoenix right like its attorney
asked I am so excited it has like an
anime intro that was just very excited
that it just picked cross but with an
anime intro and like the pig cross is
like a picture of like some clue okay
also they put out the games a couple of
years old but they just put on switch
like last week is a aviary attorney
slowly answered law yeah it's like
Phoenix right but like it's all birds
and takes excuse me joke from my hobby
that he'll appreciate when he listens to
this episode mm-hmm they're all like
different animals and they're I forget
that name of that art style but it's
like that that sort of like crosshatch
like yeah eighteen hundred's like art
style like from the old newspapers yeah
there's a name for it I'm I forget but
it like takes place in the 18th century
like Paris and I'm just like I was like
Georgia what do you think of this this
is my girlfriend she's like that is
extremely my [ __ ] she loves Birds yeah
she loves Birds she loves animals so the
idea and she's like in love with Phoenix
right so he's like that after she played
a heartful boyfriend no but I should
definitely play with I should play
I love him that's so good awful
boyfriend is so good mmm yeah
that's about it cool Callie what have
you been up to
um I saw birds of prey we all did I
wanted I haven't seen it yet so you see
except me I was gonna go Monday in the
night through my there were three other
people in the theatre there was 45 I'm
on one Monday night it was empty and I
really enjoyed it like I don't think
it's like an excellent movie or anything
but I I just I don't know I get really
excited when I see a movie that's like
explicitly targeting someone like me
that isn't like Little Women which I
still really want to see it's very good
not a knock against a little women but
it's nice to be like like I'm so tired
of comic book movies I'm really just
like I find them like tolerable when I
go see like they go through them like
basically for work so I'm like I know
what the Avengers is and I've always
liked
Batman mm-hmm so like DC is more
interesting to me so I'm like oh I know
I know Gotham like I can like follow
along but uh I just I like that it was
like okay here's all these women who are
traditionally like you see them through
the male gaze very Agha let's go ah but
I know that Harley is wearing like a
little don't booty shorts and like all
this stuff and it's it's nice to watch
movie where it's like like the Margot
Robbie is so beautiful and like half the
movie she's in they're like how do we
make you look less beautiful and they
fail but you can tell I tried like she
has you know she'll get like makeup all
over her face and you're like why you're
so gorgeous so I appreciate that but
like but not in a like the movies trying
to show you how gorgeous she is way in a
way where it's just like oh I'm really
enjoying her character I love Mary
Elizabeth Winstead as I'm so good
she was really funny and I enjoy that a
lot I just I there's stuff I really
enjoy it and I think that there are a
couple scenes that I didn't think were
necessary like the face peeling [ __ ] and
there was like kind of a rapey scene mmm
it was like a sexual violence overtones
kind of scene that I was kind of like
that didn't why did you guys think that
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah I was like especially
for the audience like if the audience is
like women who are like I want to feel
empowered because it's what kind of the
whole point of the movie is like Harley
like re empowering herself it's like why
the thing is like they do it in service
of making you hate the villain bro it's
like this this movie is for girls who
make kill all men jokes you don't have
to try that hard to make it hate it when
McGregor all right all you have to do is
be like he was kind of mean to his
girlfriend once and we'd be like kill
him I did like this I thought the face
peeling scene made sense and just making
him a super villain like a comic he'll
be like like oh here's my diabolical
plan like he does something ridiculous
like no mobster would ever do that but
he does it because it's a comic-book
movie and it's our and they want to push
it and I was like okay I think I think
that works I didn't mind
admittedly that's like the intro scene
for him versus the second senior talked
about being seen I think it's a good way
to I mean I was like really grossed out
but I think it's a good way to establish
says like oh yeah we hate him and I was
joking earlier I don't think we should
kill all men I think it's like a good
way to be like okay this guy's like
objectively evil and horrible so we
don't have to feel bad about what we do
to him for the rest of the movie and we
can just like not interrogate that at
all and just have fun but the scene with
the dress and the club did not what cuz
I'm and that was not that's so far in
the movie you already like already I
already hate him you don't need this
seems like an hour and 20 minutes to be
like oh that's who and McGregor he's
really good at being like I really enjoy
he he doesn't look like he's aged at all
since in Star Wars at least when I when
I saw that movie because I saw episode 2
before the new one yeah she looks really
young that's why I was like maybe
because he's a beard like you're looking
at was like damn you actually work that
like didn't he leave his wife Mary Mary
Elizabeth I mean you can't blame him but
like that got really messy with his door
and stuff alright let his doors like
post in like subtweeting about mmm yeah
anyway so I did that and I had fun um
and then Pokemon home came out so I
checked that out a little bit I haven't
actually transferred any Pokemon I'm I'm
gonna I'm really excited to go through
into my son are my moon safe and get
like I have a bunch of wonder traded
like foreign language Pokemon I'm sure I
have like really good dittos foreign
language to those I can transfer so a
lot of like good breeding material I'm
curious with the the wonder trade on the
app and stuff like that how they're
gonna keep track of like hacked Pokemon
glitched Pokemon and whatnot because
that seems like way more of an issue
when people are like pulling from their
old games and trading to other apps and
stuff like that like a friend of ours
like shared of screen chatting so go
look what I got from a wonder trade and
then you look at the moves and it's
oh yeah that's not real no I I've
definitely gotten hacked pokemon from
wonder trade but there there are some
that won't that will appear legal and
I've definitely gotten some that did not
appear legal as well okay so normally if
you do get a hack Pokemon will be like
this is this is an illegal Pokemon it'll
there's like a clover symbol that shows
up on the Pokemon summary page that
indicates that it's like that's the
symbol that indicates it's generated
within a Pokemon game if it doesn't have
that symbol then it is automatically
deemed illegal okay but if you were to
take like if you got for example one
Pokemon that's like illegal now that you
cannot get any more is Machamp with or
sorry ma champ is it wait I see much
chance it Machamp
I've been say Machamp anyway Machamp
with the ability no guard which all of
its moves hit a hundred percent but
every move hits it a hundred percent and
the move Fisher which is normally a
thirty percent accuracy move with no
guard it would be a hundred percent and
I said one-hit ko move that's like just
totally illegal so you could get like a
hacked Machamp with no guard and Fisher
but otherwise like you can't get that so
that it would be obvious like you could
look up if you got a Pokemon that you
weren't sure like if it was shiny and
had perfect stats I got a shiny 6iv
Heatran and wonder trade once and I was
like this definitely had but look is
like why would you trade that away if
you've got that but like um if it's
shiny and it has like perfect stats and
you're like I don't know about this one
just like look up like go on like Sara B
or something and see it's move list and
you'll see if like like oh it's just for
similar that route but there's some
Pokemon that you can transfer through
Pokemon home now that have moves that
they can't get in sword and shield cuz
sword and shield made some changes to
moves and abilities so like right now in
if you just have sword and shield you
didn't transfer from home you can't get
hidden ability clefable
but you can transfer hidden ability
clefable and then Cole fable can also
learn a move soft-boiled which heals it
and you get that you can't do that in
sword and shield either so you could
transfer them but like in the official
competitive scene you're only allowed to
use Pokemon that were born in
Galler so you can't use them anyway and
they would know that right away because
there's different symbols for the
Pokemon originates mmm yeah but the cool
thing is now with Pokemon home you can
transfer Pokemon that are like alternate
region forms because they're legal
because like Ponyta for example there's
gallery' and ponyta right and you can't
get regular fire ponyta in sword and
shield unless you transfer it from
Pokemon home and then you can breed that
Ponyta and now you have a pony table
that's the Kanto version of Ponyta and
so you can use those so like I think
people might I mean it wasn't a super
popular strategy but people might try
alone on nine tails again that was the
Pokemon minute a lot of that probably
didn't make sense made sense it made me
not sad in a way but kind of realizing
that I only have such a surface level
knowledge of Pokemon I love it when you
talk I love it when you talk passion
about anything because I'm just like
yeah she likes this and she knows the
[ __ ] so I'm just sat here enjoying it oh
I wish I liked anything as much as you
like Pokemon wait no that's not true I
like overwatch yeah you do and your when
you talk about or watch you you do the
same thing yeah I don't know anything
about a little though I just don't care
about it I'm so sorry Michael Chu I
actually I'm the same way with like
Pokemon like I don't want you thing I
have watched anime since like 2002 I'm
gonna turn this frying pan into a drying
pan that's the only one I know that and
the the band episode where James has
boobs for some reason that was banned in
the u.s. mm-hmm yeah there's an episode
where James has blue some reason they
it's like yeah and then you can see
screenshots that they don't think it
ever aired in the US no you can find it
online I just always loved when Brock
was like here have some jelly doughnuts
and that's just for kids baby just rice
balls and I legitimately as a kid was
like oh that's I guess jelly doughnuts
okay
a kid I didn't want jellied I would only
eat like a chocolate doughnut so I was
just like I guess that's what jelly
doughnuts look like i Jake I have been
playing modern warfare and what the
first time I actually like talked about
new things with it because season 2 just
started on Tuesday I think with a
whopping 68 gigabyte update at least on
xbox so I think it was as much as like
in the 90s on some platforms it was it
was a 98 update on PC so apparently
actually Matt may have been lying to me
but he said that he said that the reason
why this update is so big is because
they're basically overwriting a lot of
stuff in the original I can't trust them
from my understanding of it the reason
the game update sizes are so big is
because it depends on the way that the
developer compiled the game files okay
and so like if you compile it into one
let's say like one package excuse me if
I'm using the wrong terminology here but
like if you make changes to one file
within that package you'd essentially
have to make changes to everything okay
and so if they're changing something
substantially is for season 2 they're
gonna be changing so many files and so
many different packages that they just
have to yeah but also it seems that
they've added battle royale well not yet
but well I mean that's another thing
about this do is it Atlee in its how'd
that stuff gets date in mind all the
time is because they prepare for
upcoming patches or DLC yeah happens in
overwatch all the time too they just put
it out in an earlier patch so the game
files all there and then it just looks
like people can get at it yeah I mean I
I remember like cuz I didn't have high
speed internet growing up as a kid like
well obviously it didn't exist but then
even an even in high school I didn't
because we just lived in the middle of
nowhere most of college I didn't have it
either so like I remember when I'd want
to update a game and it would be more
than a gigabyte and I'd be like well I'm
playing this in two weeks yeah so I
definitely feel when people are on
Twitter and being like like six
gigs I'm gonna have to look my data cap
we have in the UK is data caps so when I
moved here I mean I'm very very
fortunate in that living with Greg in
particular like his main thing when he
he and Jenn moved into that place was
like we're getting the good internet so
we don't have a data cap that I know of
if we do I'm sorry cuz I found out all
my games I think yeah I don't think we
have a data cap babe usually the biggest
thing that takes up most of your data
like when you download a game update is
um either like texture packs like a fork
a texture pack or actually like audio
this is usually like uncompressed yeah
so like with calls eat in particular
it's not just that you're downloading
the audio you're also downloading the
audio for like 12 different language
packs and that takes up so much space at
least like that I remember that being
the case with previous Call of Duty's so
I kind of wish that they had the option
of like hey look I don't really only got
playing English I don't need to download
these other packs or like I don't have a
4k monitor I don't need to download the
4k textures like some games going
forward that there will be better
options for what you can and can't
download so I think it was just DLC
packs to start with right you could
decide what you could have yeah with
steam you can like when you pick your
language it installs that voice right
alright that voice pack I guess because
I remember when I was messing with that
what's your video and I was trying to do
it in Polish I'd be like oh I'm playing
polish and I'd actually go into steam
properties settings and hit it and then
I'd have an update that I have to
download it yeah same with like 4k like
I think like doom you can download like
the 4k texture pack it adds an extra 30
gigs or whatever yeah I mean I look
forward to that for next generation then
hopefully downloading is streamlined I
guess maybe unless we stream everything
unless we stream everything you're not
this gen next gen in the US will get
better regulations on our internet
companies hmm anyway season to what so I
have modern warfare I haven't touched it
I feel bad it's on my list don't feel
bad it's fine you play it all the time
yeah and every week you bring it up and
I'm like if I wasn't like cuz as well
we're doing alte carbon and Westworld
stuff
coming up so I have to agree watch all
that so that's kind of where I'm
allotting my free time to is like I'll
play a little bit but watch it but then
I have to do homework so what am I
missing out on in season two so season
two adds three new maps one is a ground
war map I forget what it's called but
it's basically like a giant I think I
think it's like a Airport sort of thing
like a destroyed everything I think I
think you can find some old modern
warfare maps in there they do that with
the last grand war map they added to
their vacant you could find terminals
like I think terminal is somewhere in
there but I think it's different I think
it's like destroyed or something you
should have had actual terminal in there
well I think they will probably break
that out I guess and make it a
multiplayer map at some point but as of
right now they've added rust and atlas
superstore I only played it out of the
superstore once I didn't love it cuz it
was just like it's just like a warehouse
with boxes throughout it it's like it's
like Home Depot but like a bunch of
boxes Costco like really take pains to
add quality Maps considering modern
warfare is like big detriment is that
the map quality is really inconsistent
well I only played I only played once so
it could've just been like you know if
you had a bad game yeah I could've had a
bad game not been wild about it and then
they have rust as well which I'm gonna
be honest I don't like rust that much
it's it like rust is the map rust is
like the meme map right everyone's like
1v1 me and rust and stuff like yeah and
I feel like they were like everyone
talks about rust there for if we're
gonna add a modern war for to map we
should add rust and I was excited for it
then I played it and I was like yeah I
never liked the rust I don't think I
wanted this there's so many great maps
in modern warfare 2 particularly that I
would have preferred I mean that's just
me like I'm sure other people are stoked
rust is there we could call your dad
again
but I think like favela is one that
would have been a great addition a state
is one that I thought was really good
and then terminal as we talked about
before I thought was another fantastic
map which I think they brought back in
modern warfare 3 if I'm not mistaken
maybe ghosts too I don't remember
I didn't play much of threes multiplayer
really bad at map names so I well like
every game has like the same like it's
like foundation like term like they all
use the same
like they all share like a group of
names that they pull from and they're
like this maps gonna be called
foundation mine where he's like the last
call due to game I like can vary that
maybe black ops but like distinctly
remember like the maps I know bug that's
wine or if you say the name I can what's
the one that's um I Hudson the desert
it's got the caves and those like the
plane in between Afghan Afghan so that's
a good I don't think they'd add that
because they already have kind of like a
that's good though but I mean like
season two also adds a new character new
character you can plays ghost which like
I don't know ghost was never that
interesting of a character for me and in
the original Modern Warfare but clearly
I'm in the my way ghost was from - right
he was like gases boy factor but but
clearly I'm a minority because everyone
is playing his ghost in multiplayer
everyone you see is just running around
his ghost but yeah I don't know there's
some good additions there there's new
weapons the ump45 I forget what they
call it in this game but it's the ump45
which was in to one or more for two and
another gun I don't remember what it was
though but yet like the guns seem like
pretty good additions like the the rust
is cool to see even though I'm not super
wild about that map I still play the
ground war map I think what I'm really
excited for though is the Battle Royale
which you know not official yet but it's
already been leaked and probably gonna
be official one time this goes out I
know they'll give it at least a week at
least be Tim's day has there been any
leaks about it outside of just hey this
is coming like so it was leaked a while
ago I think we managed to get in someone
glitched into it I think yeah cuz I
think the map like a map got leaked Ford
a long time ago and everyone was like
this is probably too big for a ground
war map so they assumed it was battle
royale cuz what I liked about blackout
was that it was sort of a fun like
mismatch of of different Call of Duty
like black ops levels and they had like
zombies in it and like I kind of liked
that it felt like he liked black like
black out I thought was pretty
and it felt like it was sort of this
weird celebration of the black ops
series like yes true as well I imagine
they'll do something similar yeah
considering in the ground war maps
they've already included old Call of
Duty maps like they've just bribed them
in those maps I have a feeling it will
just be like a giant map with a bunch of
empty spaces like dotted with old call
of duty modern warfare map sir I doubt
there'll be a ghost I guess I'm just
curious if like they're gonna do
anything unique with this version of
their bowels yeah or is it just gonna be
black out Lucy's got something I do
ecology mom off a battle royale mode
discovered through glitch so it's
apparently called war zone Charlie Intel
which is website that specializes in
called GE sort of news and leaks there
are a bunch of people on Twitter -
they've glitched into the menu for the
mode come on yeah images from the menu
show option for weapons operators and
barracks or while a page for drop kits
that you can edit before matches has
also popped up additionally people have
claimed to be able to see the new battle
royale map by various and unconfirmed
means and there is an entire video of
the room and map posted on line
interesting so actually the modern
warfare 2 seasons you update the modern
warfare season 2 updates re has a new
classified page on the game's title
screen yeah so when you load up the game
there's like there's like what is it
like story like multiplayer like
something that's like crossed out and
like hidden and then SpecOps so there's
a spot for whatever this new I really
hope it waits until after pax well you
wouldn't review the mode right or would
we yeah we review DLCs when appropriate
that's true
and yeah that's an interesting strategy
like you feel like they would want to be
like to let you know it's coming to like
get people like hey make sure to buy our
game but like that's interesting that
they've decided to like try and keep it
Wilton to be honest I think it works
pretty well that their rather than just
releasing everything right away
they're doing big content updates on new
seasons and then throughout that season
they're giving more and more content
like even the last season they added a
couple new maps throughout it they added
new weapons and all that stuff was like
I don't know they just add fun new
challenges like okay now I'm gonna
unlock the crossbow here so I got to do
this sort of stuff to get it you finally
completed your crossbow challenge isn't
you I completed a while ago and then I
got it and I was like this gun sucks
[Music]
yeah the thing about modern warfare
warfare battle royale is that like like
black ops it would have made more sense
to have like heroes kind of like a mechs
like we've had like a legend kind of
thing because there were actually
classes in multiplayer and this I mean
it's probably gonna be more like a
military battle royale like blackout or
pokey yeah I'm curious cuz like my thing
that I want to see the most I don't know
if it's gonna be good but I'm tired of
battle royale games with armor like pick
up armor of different tiers because like
at least apex you can if you shoot
someone they'll like that color armor
will like flash so he's like okay they
got a purple I gotta I gotta lean back a
little bit but honestly I kind of want
to see what it's like to play battle
royale game where there's no armor at
all um or maybe there's just like one
standard armor so there's no so like mmm
hardcore kind of yeah but also Oh time
to kill the problem with that though
right is that snipers will just dominate
yeah so that that'll be really
interesting and like I don't know the
customize drop boxes or whatever like
maybe you can put your loadout in that
and if you get it you just get one of
your load outs or something like that
like that could be kind of interesting
yeah you mentioned apex that briefly I
just want to give a shout out to max for
getting to the top of the apex subreddit
oh yeah insane video so max is
incredible
at apex I'm only like have you seen any
of our guides it's usually backs
capturing the footage they're mice
Blumenthal on our game's team and he did
he got this game where he should have
died 11 times
and he like freeze frames it and puts
text on and kind of points out stuff
that I didn't even notice is it stuff
like a grenade bouncing off a crate that
misses him and then it's it's the most
insane game I've ever seen my favorite
is when he counts out the number of
shotgun shots of the one person trying
to shoot him with and missed every eight
times like there's one there's one
there's one there's one
he hits two self revives in one game yes
I gotta watch this video it's really
good and I was like yeah I shout at the
mics what's gonna happen to your crew
when a battle royale comes out I mean
you're on because every man for himself
oh that's a good point split up well
that's another weird thing about Call of
Duty is that like I'd leave they'll be
like like you played 10 V 10 domination
we'll have seven people in the bag now
you can only have six and it's like but
why it's 10 V 10 or like for some reason
shipment only let you do even though
it's 66 they don't leave that groups of
five oh yeah we couldn't play yeah so
it's just kinda like like I get I get
why you wouldn't want ten people in a
6v6 game type because then they'd just
spilling over and they're the team but
like a 10 V 10 why can't eight of us
just go together in a 10 V 10 right I
wonder if just if they're they have
matchmaking invitations or something
yeah I mean that's probably it honestly
but no that's that's what I have to say
about Modern Warfare season 2 mm-hmm
what if it's like they're expecting a
lot of like groups of two and three and
they want to make sure those people get
into games that could be it - mm-hmm
I could see that so should we talk about
Jeff Keely this week newswise but this
morning we film on Wednesdays Jeff
pulled out of p3e threes dead man it's
over man so somebody else is doing the
ìiî Coliseum then because he just said
he wasn't doing I don't know he I
thought that was like his production he
says I have made the difficult decision
to decline to produce III coliseu that
implies that someone else can produce it
right
it's a strange
but you're right that days like
associated with him but it's fine yeah
it's very much associated with him and I
mean he's the guy who organizes it yeah
I feel like a lot of those guests the
reason they're there is because Jeff
Keely can get them there it's weird
because I feel like I know III there's
been a lot of like it's changing and
it's gonna work very differently but the
the Coliseum was always kind of worked
with the whole like he's getting a crowd
in and they're sitting down it was
outdoors if I'm correct right it was
kind of wait you talking about it so I
think Jeff's live from e3 which is in
the lobby of JW Marriott which is all
the developer stuff but then the
Coliseum were talks with like Kojima and
Cory bar log and so there was two
different myths so whether he still do
live at e3 or not I have no idea but if
he's not doing the the public things
well there's the public facing stuff
which is the talks there's like the
regular dev interviews and then similar
to what we do like he'll just get people
in although he does say for the first
time in 25 years I will not be
participating in a 3 yes he's just not
there yeah cuz he's one of like four
people who've been to every single what
does he know that we don't uh III yeah
probably everything everything leads all
of his information no I don't think they
leaked his I did see the list I found
that it was just exhibitors right yeah
we were fine because we were exhibitors
so he would've been fine because he was
an exhibitor but yeah the list from the
ESA but then the ESA also said that like
Nintendo's definitely still there guys
so just slowly he's been taking up more
and more space for Microsoft to write
it's still supposed to be not inside the
convention center that gonna be in the
Microsoft theater but so they're gonna
show are they still gonna have like
there no oh really
actually cuz I went to that yeah my
first III as like immediate like in the
industry it was like
crate like you would go out to any place
and there'd be everybody you know there
everybody was drunk like wasted drunk
and then now it's like I'm gonna go to
bed it's like 9:30 and I'm really erred
so like I don't know if that's just me
getting older if III is like getting
chiller I think something chilla because
there's more events now yeah cuz in 2015
I remember going to the fig and it was
like everybody I'd ever heard of mm-hmm
popping off and it was like be careful
because yesterday somebody fell in the
pool you know like
so III not that like I need to do that
ever again I already did that a couple
times not fall in the pool like go to
party II threes but like it's just weird
to I'm not worried about like the death
of III or anything cuz I think like
that's not like the death of the
industry it's just kind of weird to be
like oh you know if you were a fewer
people go and like our international
friends aren't always there and mm-hmm
I can't I don't think it needs to be the
two holes anymore cuz it's like last
year oh yeah I mean you could start to
see it kind of creep the last few years
but like the US army would have a bigger
booth than some games which was good but
yeah with Sony pulling out with
Microsoft moving out EA - they always
used to have a huge booth I hope they do
nothing again
well cuz do you remember last year it
was so boring there's like they talked
about the their biggest thing they
talked I was like a peck season 2 which
was cool right it's cool it was cool but
it was like I don't I'm not gonna sit
through a four-hour press conference
see an update on a gamester I want to
see like what's coming I had to do that
because I was like on called Rhino story
I was there - I was watching the whole
thing and I was like this is yeah I
I hope they either if I hope they figure
something out because if they do the
same thing I'm not watching it
[Music]
Sims five man I said they're working on
another Sims I mean if if they were
gonna do a four-hour one and they're
like you know we're gonna end it with
Mass Effect the new Mass Effect game or
you in just the Mass Effect trilogy
yesterday I'd be okay with it but we all
know keep the dream alive Jake I'm
trying Ubisoft will be there you'll be
there yeah Ubisoft announced a new
Splinter Cell I'm sorry man
keep the dream alive it's too late it's
all gone
but I mean Jeff's still doing uh Opening
Night Live at Gamescom he didn't say
that he said that game will still be a
thing I imagine Sony went hard at Paris
games week a few years ago they might do
the same again the PS my life I don't
know Paris games week is a woeful show I
do not like bears games week when do you
think we'll see we'll finally see the
bear like new console press conferences
or whatever la I mean why soon it has to
be I don't think I don't think I'll be
this month I think maybe you know I
don't think 43 next months I feel like
if you're the oldest coming in may you
think may yeah April or May like after
last of us should make a bet yeah I I
think they probably won't wait actually
windows last was come out May May ma'am
okay June I think your and XIII oh [ __ ]
Marconi III I know like I say much
I'm putting my bet on March I'll say
like I don't know anything I don't know
anything
yeah we don't know anything yes yes
people don't feel don't tell snakes uh I
mean I yes
you can say a month that we've already
said I I guess I'll go with April April
crew I mean I don't know why we care
tomorrow's got a ps5 and his desk yes
doesn't really matter
Peter's got an Xbox on his desk to know
cuz I saw it and time came up to me
holding it and I was genuinely taken
aback by it
I thought we don't know any had that
clerks series already got one and it was
Oh big fellas got it filled big Phil's
got it in his house maybe we maybe he
sent he sent us one of his personal ones
I met big Phil I just didn't know what
to say to him it's like don't tell him
in your head every time you hear felt
you calling Bigfoot which is like don't
say it but like just from a random thing
I told I told you why I make that
Association it's because there's a
there's an old video where a guy
introduces himself and he goes hi my
name's Phil my friends call me big Phil
but he's like a skinny guy like Phil
again like a svelte guy I'm not saying
he's big or anything but it's like I
just automatically make it so every time
we had Jeff Keely I hear pouring went
out for my fellow Jeffery which is a
tweet that Geoff Keighley did when Toys
R Us went under and he quotes weird a
quote we had a picture of the giraffe
named Jeffrey no Jeffrey and he said
poor enough my thigh will give you so
like I'm my entire monthly paycheck if
at e3 you call him big Phil on the stage
if you say I'm here with not bi-weekly
no no the whole thing put me up there
games industry big fills Phil Harrison
is the tallest film I don't think
there's a chart of Phil so he's the big
film but it's more like symbolically yes
the big thing yeah he is the big cheese
have been Jay Kahoot is often known by
the name Phil yeah it's true because of
his handle philanthropy
all the Phils all sorts ah it's very
weird for me as a British person because
in the UK there is a TV host call Phil
Spencer who hosts the show called
Location Location Location spelled
exactly the same so when it's genuinely
when when you move when you're in the UK
and you search Phil Spencer comes up
with that Phil then you move here you
search for Phil spend so it comes up
with big home I I met big Phil one time
at Brazil game show and Brazil game show
because they sent this one here because
they sent me it was like me in bed and
Randy there and we interviewed yes yeah
we were supposed to interview Hideo
Kojima but he peaced out last minute we
like God everything set up we had the
room set up and he was just like and
then and what was even better is I
looked over and he was doing a signing
like right next to our booth that's true
but anyway we asked about destiny and he
like showed us his destiny socks Oh big
they'd filled it not not hit anyway
that's my big phil story and i think
that's all the stories we have move
right on into questions yeah it's been
such a quite week I tomorrow's a dice in
Vegas and Tam doesn't drink smoke Oh
gamble so what a place Vegas much baby
you know babe yeah you're not to vape
indoors in Vegas welcome to the big
things of the modern warfare season two
and pokemon home with there are two
versions the mobile version and this
Petrosian they have like one or two
overlapping features but are pretty
distinct and they interact with each
other so like the mobile version is
where all the trading happens the switch
version is like compatible stuff in
pokemon sword and shield that's the we
have a whole faq of pokemon home like
pricing and what the different versions
do i did a thing on how to breed
regional for
because you have to do a specific thing
to get like a loan loan Vulpix or
whatever and oh and we have a story on
all of the pokémon that are now
available to be transferred there were
like there were like 30 or so that were
data mined and they weren't available so
like squirtle and Bulbasaur because
Charmander is in the game but the other
two starters weren't those are now
transferable and they're separate from
like the Pokemon that are gonna be added
through the DLC car fields in it - right
you're talking about insider' or yeah
that's event always calls listener are
anyway doing read the first question
Kelly because I'm the only one who has
an answer apologies I do have to go the
bathroom but please continue without me
stay safe Thank You Chuck in a beer it's
also the furthest possible place so far
so far anyway hey y'all after watching
and really enjoying birds-of-prey it
took me much longer than it should have
to realize that Black Canary was played
by Jess from season four and five of
Friday Night Lights so it got me
thinking what have been some of your
favorite post Friday Night Lights
performances by the cast you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna stop I'm gonna actually
stop there I love this question because
it assumes that everyone in this room
knows a lot about Friday Night Lights
which is not the case I watched a lot of
Friday Night Lights and I just want to
say Connie Britton in American Horror
Story yeah I've never seen Friday Night
Lights but I love Connie Britton all I
know about Friday Night Lights is was it
clear heart full mind wise that's the
word but they do it like clear eyes full
hearts can't lose
yeah it's very American so anyway my
answer is Connie Britton in American
Horror Story she was also in Dear John
mm-hmm which is a sort of a true-crime
thing I didn't watch it but my mom did
wait utopia Zachary no your job mm-hmm
dramatization of a con-artist guy who
marries Connie Britton's character and
Lang does shady things and she was also
in a movie that I have not seen either
bombshell
which is the Fox News ladies fighting
against a costume design I think it
Ernie okay well once something hair make
I don't know oh who is it it's Connie
Britton who played Margot Robbie's in it
but she doesn't play like a real person
she was like a she's like a new
character and then I think who plays it
Charlize their own plays megyn kelly
which I find very entertaining isn't oh
man what's her name Nicole Kidman's in
it but I was looking at Connie Britton's
filmography and it said bombshell I
don't know who she plays in bombshell
I haven't seen Friday Night Lights but I
can say that Colonel Tigh from about so
glad Takei is in Sonic the Hedgehog hell
yeah so oh you know who's your Friday
Night Lights Michael B Jordan oh okay
so that's another one we can just say
everything can we just say everything
after Friday night's be like about yeah
man creed 1 & 2 those two movies are
pretty good genlock I haven't seen but I
know he was in that you had any money um
I'm going to continue the question now
hopefully John Lear comes in time
because this one applies to Jon link as
well second unrelated question I know
that almost some of all flash most
slushed some of you all baseball I have
been to Japan and was wondering what
your wait John leg this is the listen to
this question I know that all of you
have been to Japan and was wondering
what your big recommendations for Tokyo
are I'm going with friends for the third
time so any unusual or
off-the-beaten-track recommendations
would be particularly appreciated thanks
all and keep up the great work
Stuart from Glasgow so I feel like I
have nothing to add because if he's
going for his third time I would say go
to second best melon pond and get a
melon pond from there fresh and then eat
it while you walk well don't eat it
while you walk but take it to yo yogi
Park it's like across the street from
you do you park and sit down eat your
melon pond it's really nice and then you
can throw away the trash in the cafe
area of your yoga park so you're not
carrying it around
trash cans in Japan I really like second
best melon pond it's the I think the
reason it's called second best is just
to be humble you wouldn't call yourself
like Ichiban melon pond I'm trying to
look at like Co facedowns yeah I was
gonna say I'm trying to look up a place
named list of capsules so I went to the
old capital of Japan of the last time I
went what's it called
I'm gonna look it up keep talking well
like it's cuz Edo and Tokyo are this
same place yeah three times done before
so what I went to Kamakura Oh which is
about an hour outside of Tokyo and there
are loads of beautiful temples and
shrines time and I went with our friend
Ken and Ken is from Japan from Tokyo and
he was telling us the differences
between like shrines and the differences
between temples and you know sort of the
way that you're supposed to
traditionally act like the way that you
bow the way that you wash your hands and
kind of go in so that was really cool
beautiful place incredible food so
common core is very nice place to visit
Ghibli museum if you haven't been you
got to get to take if it's have to book
two months in advance the problem is you
often have to get for the the jewel in
museum you have to get like somebody in
Japan to reserve your ticket for you
because they aren't they don't take
kindly to like foreigners reserving so
when I went the first time I went in
2016 the website was fine but I tried to
book again because Tom hadn't been and
we were going on that work trip and I
looked and the website was completely
different and the website was basically
no you cannot buy tickets even though
this is about a month out it was about
recent thing yeah having been selling
tickets up out of Japan so that's a
shame but if you can definitely go it's
in me Sakura you should check out the
the new Nintendo store that I open or
you go it's better than managed to get
that
we went opening weekend yeah the second
day I will pay someone to give me that
animal crossing cooking pyv I tried to
go again you did three days later and
the queue was still I can't believe you
I would have just given up a friend of
mine is that right now and she was
posting on her instace story just
waltzing into the new Nintendo no I've
seen videos appeal just walk in and I
was like you man we went all the way up
Oh God we're like I guess this is the
line and it turned out it was the line
to leave because we didn't send us down
into the basement where the parking
garage and we could have we could have
gotten in the shorter capcom line yeah
we did go the capcom store was that's
good Oh was it not good no well I mean I
mean it's all some stuff just wasn't
great stuff to I would say is not worth
it it was fun when we went to the Hyatt
Regency the bar from lost in translation
oh yeah like way too expensive and they
we left it really early like it was
basically closing up shop at about 10:00
p.m.
however they had the fanciest toilet of
all yeah it's got to be really fancy
that was like it was so fat
there wasn't like paper towels there was
like hand towels that would drop into
like a hole it was but every drink was
$20 whole so yeah we all had one yeah I
think I had like one beer and I was like
what is the highest like your centage
that you can give me um I would say if
you like matcha desserts in a Saxa if
you go to since Shoji temple which is I
think a pretty popular destination
that's not off the beaten track that's
the red temple in kind of like an older
district of Tokyo but there is a matcha
calf oops I hit my mic there's a matcha
cafe there that has like fresh matcha
mochi and much of desserts I'm not like
the biggest matcha dessert fan I I think
I needed a little bit sweeter than that
I love mochi
but matcha can get a little yeah
the yeah but um it's like fresh fresh
fresh mochi and there's like a cute
there's cute little cafes like
traditional you're sitting on a tatami
mat in front of a table and that's in a
Sakai which is an older district but be
where the toilets are the hole in the
ground kind of yeah that's around there
so a place that I really like which is
not really touristy thing but there is a
spa in shinjuku called there may you and
it's about $20 for a day pass it's at
one of those 24-hour places yeah and
they have different levels so in the
basement there's a bar and just
basically reclining chairs a little TV
in mm-hm
so you can just sort of sit and relax
and then on one floor is a nonsens
there's a male and a female one there's
a massage room there's hot stones
there's treatment things so if you're
just looking to relax in the middle of
Tokyo and you want to go somewhere cheap
that's full of locals it is a naked
onsen I will say that's if you have
tattoos they are easing up on that there
is a sign that says you know if you have
fashioned tattoos just tell us some
especially if you're a foreigner and
we'll come up cover them um but if you
are covered I don't think that would fly
but it's really nice and super cheap and
also the restaurant in the basement is
we need nice yeah is that the one you
went to you that was near yeah five
minute walk from my hotel yeah I I
should have done that it was real nice I
got in 19 minute massage and it was so
good that I passed out for a little
while yeah yeah
don't take the next question Lucy so I
will say before you read this one was
quite long so I had to cut it down a bit
one thing that I did have to cut down is
Chase who wrote in was saying that we we
were a little too harsh on the Dark
Knight Rises last week he says even
though you know it may not be the best
of those movies that doesn't mean it's a
bad movie it's still very good it's got
its problems still really good I just
wanted to make sure that comes across
because I had to cut a lot of that
crushing this blows have you seen the
oral notes video of have you seen their
heads it's the football scene but it's
like a gender-reveal know the smoke to
be like pink or something will say
what's her face the she's like French or
something
her death scene in that movie is
terrible she dies like she is bad I told
you remember that she's like in a car
yes
I've only seen her do to hurt she she's
just kind of like like it's like not
good anyway I don't know anything about
the dumb time right I saw it one time
yeah I've seen it top-tier still slaps
watched it for the 10th anniversary
couple years ago yeah as someone who has
attempted to play both the witch 3 and
Dragon Age Inquisition on at least five
occasions and just failed to really get
more than 5 to 6 I was in I was inspired
by Lucy who mentioned she recently went
and played The Witcher 3 to completion
to go back and replay The Witcher 3
while playing I have noticed this
connection between some of these RPGs in
a lot of times your dialogue options do
not match what the character actually
ends up saying which can lead to some
very frustrating I'll be at some most
times funny moments so my question is
have you guys ever experienced this and
do you have any examples of times and
games where the dialogue options did not
match what the character ended up saying
it's all can RPG makers just add an
annoyed in parenthesis at the end of the
choice so you know the tone thank you
from chase I will say I remember a lot
of people complain about this with Mass
Effect the Mass Effect games because
they they weren't specific enough to
what Shepard would actually say the
wheel idaite didn't bother me I didn't
really notice that until I played Mass
Effect Andromeda because I pick things
in my character would say something
completely different or be like what
well because in trauma 2 at least with
Mass Effect the the trilogy it's like
Paragon like renegade and then the
middle ones kind of like the neutral
option like Andromeda went for that
weird like sassy versus perfed
channel and it just created this weird
like you're not can I help you sorry you
said renegade night I thought about
tick-tock they created this weird thing
where you're like I don't you know
what's that which part of the brain is
this part of and yeah you think so
logically here or you think Dragon Age 2
and I think you positioned it as well
where they actually have like little
symbols it'll have like a symbol that
means sarcastic and I was like that's
really smart more games should do that I
remember like I think fallout 3 was like
a really bad or not follow through
follow for it was only bad example yeah
where I was like I hate this dialogue
system like everything I'm trying to say
does not come across the way I want it
to say disco Elysium does this but in a
really good way mm-hmm like disk Elysium
I was like like if you choose like this
the like moderate options it almost
always goes badly for you cuz they're
like you stupid weasel like why you
can't achieve meant for being seen do
you literally get like an achievement
that makes fun of you for being a
centrist in that game so I think I
didn't get that did you get that yeah I
definitely do but no one else would get
it and I tend a noob a go did you get it
Cali but I guess other people got it
I also got the achievement for
apologizing too much hey sorry cop I
just googled something that to make sure
that I wasn't miss remembering it but
there was a bit in LA noire where you're
interrogating someone and you hit doubt
and Cole Phelps yells can I use the
f-word you [ __ ] young boys Valdez okay
but like whoa it's a doubt option and
then Cole Phelps just screams that at
him and it's you'd think with doubt you
go but no he immediately just screams I
hate his face I forgot about that
because I think LA noire is actually a
very good example of this because we
took out of the switch departments like
an error just like they accidentally
mixed up some consciousness that though
like that that's an extreme example but
like I remember in general I got a car
we got it we got to take this carefully
and I'd hit like something that seems
subtle and be like you killed him right
there I have proof and it's just like
what no I don't know proof why are you
saying this Cole like simmer down please
show out yeah it's done he's becoming
one of my favorite characters in Mad Men
oh yeah got that Lee half the cast of
Mad Men is in my head but and also
curious
Garrus is also a garis for koreans in it
um he's a he's a [ __ ] but he's a
secret poet great torch it is incredible
Mad Men is a good show
I'll watch that one of these days anyway
that was that was mine Eleanor yeah
pretty much any game we're like they
don't give you the full like what you're
actually gonna say it's that abbreviated
version like I love Mass Effect but it
started that trend and is mmm
I like it because I will read it and
then I have to hear it again I'm like I
just read that that's fair I mean like I
know why they do that it also keeps the
flow of things quicker yeah don't mind
it like in the winter you didn't mind at
all honestly like cuz yeah you're I like
the full the full sentence stuff is
usually from RPGs where your character
doesn't talk so like if it's voiced I
think that would be too much because
you'd read it and then you have to hear
it yeah and then you would have to
interrupt the spoken with like another
full sentence so you won't even listen
to them deliver the line because you're
reading the next line right so I think
there's there's I mean it's fair they
just need to add that Dragon Age thing
of like give me an idea like sim style
little like hearts to be like I'm trying
to sex you one do want to do a whoohoo
anyway it's Valentine's Day happy
Valentine's but I'd shoot shoes hello
everyone what's a game you all really
enjoy that got negative or middle in
response for most people one that stands
out for me is Paper Mario sticker star
I'm pretty sure I'm alone on loving that
game also Callie please please please
please do more polka Monday night combat
with Jo Choa I don't have any interest
in playing Pokemon competitively
Pettit of Lee but I loved watching you
two talk about it keep up the good work
race it's my name in Seattle so I have a
friend back home named race felt the
same way and everything so I was
surprised they didn't know I never seen
another person name race we also we also
had you on community Fridays last week
where we played Pokemon as well very
informative a game spot show not a giant
bomb show so you should watch that
instead or both it's fine I really like
being on money that combat is fun
Pokemon didn't come in anyway I this
question I'm always the reverse I am all
I always I'm I'm my I get into trouble
when I dislike a game that everybody
else likes mmm I mean off the top of my
head I really liked rage - I know a lot
of people didn't like that game thought
it was okay but I thought that game was
great play it was Michael I am like that
game and he reviewed it for games but
I'd like to like I think I like that
quite a bit more than him I would say I
liked it but I didn't feel compelled to
finish it - I I finished it just because
it was so short like I was I'll see I
was off I think if that game was any
longer I would have not finished it and
I probably would have stepped away from
him being pretty negative but I just
thought it was like a really fun 10 to
12 hours shooter with like not a giant
open world but big enough or he'd get
lost in and a nice reasonable checklist
of things to do and the combat was great
it was just in combat
I just want to give a shout out to Chloe
rad who is an editor with us because
Chloe would definitely say rain world
it's Chloe's like oh wow that like a
bunch of people did not like I've know a
lot of people I've never heard anyone
talk negatively about we give it a
really good game to I believe so I just
want to give shout I haven't played rain
world but I want to give a shout-out to
rain world I would say I really liked
this is a weird one because Animal
Crossing fans will Animal Crossing fans
go hard I really liked happy home
designer I reviewed that game at IGN I
gave it an 8 which is probably a little
- being honest with myself but I really
enjoyed happy home designer I liked
designing the homes I have a passion for
that sort of thing and I think a lot of
people were more middling on that game
the the WiiU Animal Crossing game though
mmm
the Wii U board game 100 I'm I'm
reasonable in that sense sorry to cut in
we gave reign world a 5 out of 10
however 97% liked it it it seems most
people reviewed it pretty high so it's
just oh I think I journal so didn't like
it very much
we've got Jen too but maybe they've
updated and patched it a ton since then
and I haven't played it don't know a lot
about it but I will say in the games
industry Twitterverse it would seem that
GameSpot is sort of alone in in loving
Red Dead - as much as we did
I feel like games driving to an test
training mm-hmm my god I love des
trending and then like well des training
was actually more dispersed Red Dead I
feel like after Red Dead came out more
and more people were like actually that
games kind of trash and then I it
tortured me for a long time I'm sorry so
this is a good question but it makes me
sad no what could a negative response
that I've liked a dead redemption - is
fantastic
if I had the time if I have if I had
Bernhard's watch I would stop it and
just play Red Dead I'm gonna go back and
play it I never finished it I want to
play to get on PC
yeah mmm I'm almost done with my second
playthrough I should finish it cuz every
time I started thinking about some of
those scenes I won't spoil anything but
like just I've not been boiled on it
hits all right I feel like I need to
take advantage and like especially with
the news that is a dan Houser and how's
their left hands like I want to see that
game through a second time just because
this is last game I guess they respect
Bioshock 2 I love both of you that's a
good one because so many people came
around on Bioshock
Minerva's Den Man mine is Dragon Age 2 a
lot of people hate I like the companions
a lot I love the companion so there's a
lot of stuff like on there is a lot of I
think all the criticisms towards that
game are like completely valid like I
can't necessarily disagree with anybody
but like I really like the companions I
like what they tried to do with the
story where it is just like it's more
about like the life of this character
and it's not this like like it's a very
untraditional Bioware story where it
doesn't have that like like what I
didn't like about Inquisition was that
it kind of went back to that buyer or
formula of like you're the chosen one
and like this and that and like I kind
of like that like Dragon Age is about
like you are a refugee who has to like
kind of like see you jump yeah you lost
jobs and sort of like become like this
more important person and it felt more
like rewarding but I distinctly remember
like I think it wasn't like when I was
on the giant bomb forms back in the day
there's a threat of like tell us your
your games that you know that you're
unpopular gaming opinions no judgment
here and I was like I like Dragon Age 2
and then sown immediately responded with
like go [ __ ] yourself this was a
judgment-free zone I I will say I love
it when especially fantasy games don't
put you in the shoes of the Savior or
the person who's gonna save the universe
like one of the reasons why I like The
Witcher 3 so much one of them
reasons is that you're not actually
playing the Savior one of the reasons
why I think I live ian is better than
Skyrim is that you're not playing like
this shows Howard chosen one you're just
a guy trying to like it's like helping
the chosen one the chosen one do you
need to do and I really hope especially
like Elder Scrolls six I hope I hope
they go back to that but just in general
I hope fantasy and even sci-fi games
kind of think about that for a second
and maybe maybe you don't need to be the
hero of the story to tell such an
interesting even Morland I remember like
yeah Moreland's the whole thing is like
like you're supposedly the chosen one
but like the actual the game actually
gets into like people being like know
that it's based on like an old
prophesying people like that's actually
[ __ ] and like it doesn't matter so
like it kind of actually like messes
with that idea I also really like Dragon
Age 2 because it it had the the Mass
Effect 3 dialogue wheel and had like
super nice Boy Scout like super dickish
but for their nutri option they went
like just sarcastic [ __ ] and that's
how I played it and so like the whole
game you're just delivering like Arnold
Schwarzenegger style like one-liners the
whole time and it's really [ __ ] up
like there's a couple times where like
some really like messed up things happen
or like some major characters happen and
you just like click the sarcastic option
and you're like I shouldn't do this I'm
gonna do it and then you just say
something like really flipping and
messed up and everyone's like what is
wrong with you and I've never seen a
game quite let me be that kind of person
so I really appreciate Dragon Age 2 for
letting me do that hey Evan give a game
that you like that everyone doesn't seem
to like or hates I've honestly been
thinking about it the entire time I
can't think of one right now I'm so
disappointed unless it's got perfect
tastes I forgot the three of us really
liked pray oh not here right now
I wish tan was here cuz Tam gave one of
the best games of what 2017 yeah yeah we
there were a bunch of us that were like
Mike my hearty - we were like really
really like pray and Tim was like here's
all the reasons
kind of [ __ ] and we were like where do
you stand sit normally cuz I have like a
really nice prey poster under my desk
that I've been waiting to put in the
office so I thought you I would say when
is time six I've got a real nice pot
brewing I just want to have like a
prayer poster just strategically
position ever
temps it's on the podcast well he says
just want it right there the shot so you
look forward to that I will so if I rend
the bugs oh I got one oh let's here I
think they have aged pretty well and I
enjoy them okay okay okay so Jake can
you repeat that for the encased people
get in here
no they should build it's it's hooked up
right yeah oh he should be here the
voice of God to respect that
I play the hell out of Sonic Adventure 2
battle on GameCube because of the chao
garden I was gonna say is the Chao Gert
that's exactly like I literally was
gonna then my next question was gonna be
like is that the one with the chao
garden because I respect that I never
played one though but one isn't one the
one where sonic makes out with a real
person no that's that's so 6 that's the
bad one
ok well you know if we want to go down
that rabbit hole to bring a brac back to
pray though I will say if I ran into
some of the bugs tomorrow did I probably
wouldn't like to do no or like some of
the bugs we ran into I just didn't see
it all like I played through that whole
game fine and I uh I played on ps4 too
but PC was even better like I replayed
on PC and PC was really good like if you
were turned off by prey initially maybe
just because of how it felt just because
the bugs I highly recommend going back
to it to more especially if you can on
PC because is brilliant Xbox the loading
times are pretty bad but my philosophy
like I do this with most reviews it's
like I it depends on the bug and if
they're like pretty severe that can
totally affect a score typically I don't
because I'm like well bug could be
patched up and you can't like
totally undo bad game design decisions
of that like that warranting a new
review kind of like that's like the DNA
of the game is yes it's not perfect it
it's ending as you say that stasis
welcome last hours is rough and
especially on console because you're
just traveling across the steps I'm just
hitting loading screen after loading
screen after loading don't realize it
hits and speeds but gameplay wise it
does out state as welcome I will not
deny that I have friends who liked
dangan ronpa one but hate danganronpa to
like hate it
well no were like okay and then one time
Jen my roommate was like Kelly you know
dongyeop is not a good game like like
it's like a good story it was not good
good like you know that and I was like
an excellent game like how dare you it's
like people like when people when I'm
like I love Deadly Premonition it's like
one of my favorite games everyone's like
okay ever like it's like no I just like
ironic right in a more you know I love
it like no irony detected this is the
[ __ ] that I like I owned it three times
and I've played it I think I've played
the other Premonition like five times
you know what's a game that like a lot
of people really got into the Kim
Kardashian mobile game oh yeah that was
trending for a while for us yeah oh yeah
I never I never played it I need someone
who would spent hundreds of pounds on
Simpson stepped out though really yeah I
was really into hit and run hidden run
was great weren't there rumors that
there was gonna be a remaster
I would love that that would be so
posting groups and that's the the meme
of the month right now is hit and run
remastered okay wasn't it like
specifically there was like some live
stream where they were like oh they're
gonna now it's like a remaster and then
it was like a like a mobile thing or
something it was like the announcement
thing that was like super depressed like
oh okay well maybe next time I mean I
guess another game spongebob squarepants
battle for bikini bottom
I don't know if that reviewed well cuz I
didn't I didn't I didn't have internet
at that time but that game was great and
I'm very excited for the remaster and
then I can
it's probably remembered but when I was
on PS I love you xoxo when we were doing
the fantasy draft I almost picked
Spongebob Squarepants battle for bikini
bottom remaster because that game owns
and Barrett was like in the back being
like somebody buy it and I was like I
might actually do it and then I
chickened out
I might go back and buy it though
because I mean the point of the fantasy
draft was like picking games that we
thought would review well right so I was
like I mean I'll have fun was that game
was published by THQ with Simpsons Hit &
Run also published by THQ probably not
but it seems like a game that THQ a did
the movie game which was not good yet I
actually like the movie game it's not no
you're right it's because I played hit
and run before and I was like this game
is great and then I played the movie
game so I never played it round I just
played the movie game it was radical and
published by Vivendi Vivendi okay well
that's probably ever get I never play
bad bottom because they didn't own a
console as a kid so road rage was my
preferred actually some I really liked
road rage road rage is good - that was
radical as well I did play the spy was
that was yeah yeah I thk movie game
which on PC was like a point click
adventure that's pretty funny oh dang
that'd be kind of a spongebob point
clicking ready for that it was like the
piece is like that own thing and it was
like a point click adventure game and I
was pretty into it anyway that's been
episode 28 of GameSpot after dark my
name is Jake deck can you find me at
Jacob deck Lucy where can people find
you I'm at Lucy James games Cowie on
everything I'm at Aikido chico i am k yd
o ji k k Oh John Luke no you do not do
this to me again please I have
misophonia
don't do it please don't do it
janek's IP thank you seriously I can't
listen to people make eating noises and
I sit in the Bermuda Triangle of people
who eat loud unintentionally and I can't
I feel like I can't ask them because you
can't you can't say hey don't you just
stop eating right now but if those boys
three bose noise-canceling i do try and
be very conscious of like I'm always
worried that I'm eating too loud I'm
like I don't want to disturb people over
stimulation day to day 2 where I was
just like I heard food from one noise
and like from one sorry but before
before we get off one thing I do want to
talk about before we get off topic one
thing is the discord a lot of people are
still writing about discord any updates
on the discord I just want you to get
that email to Randy about it Randy's
been very busy last couple weeks so I
didn't want to bother him about it but I
am going to do that I've got to make it
happen I guarantee it being in a big
corporation that like yeah you just have
to jump through a million different yeah
you just send out a thing you're like
Idol hopefully hear back about that I've
gotten quite a few messages and emails
being like hey I'm feel bad because it's
no one's fault but at the time it was
like oh no it'll it'll probably happen
and then when I kind of came back click
so ready right and he's like oh we need
to do a couple more things so I was like
oh ok well I feel bad now that I kind of
put that out there but it's all good
so anyway is everyone gonna have a nice
Valentine's Day yeah nope so yeah can't
wait to get these contacts out of my
eyes Isak Valentine's Day it's my
Valentines but I'm gonna get pizza and
play Blood Moon
nice hey don't have anything I mean I
say that's that's the plan I'm making
that the blood see you next week bye
[Music]